bakugo's Quirk is Awakening through one
for all bakugo and Deku just changed the
course of Fate itself and all for one's
master plan is collapsing but is this
the end of the villains or is this just
the beginning of the real epic battle
mha is out of control right now so let's
get into it you guys know how this works
if you enjoy my mha content and you want
to see more in the future leave a quick
like and comment for that YouTube
algorithm and if you want to help this
channel awaken the true power of its
Quirk by hitting 2 million subscribers
on YouTube please do me a big favor and
subscribe right now we are so close
finally this video will of course
contain mha manga spoilers so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned in the previous chapter we saw
that night ey's tragic prediction about
all might's fate had been changed thanks
to the power of everyone all over the
world who was rooting for all might and
wishing for his victory and also thanks
thanks to some epic teamwork from our
boys Deku and bakugo thanks to a major
Boost from deku's gear shift bakugo was
able to zoom to All For One in all
might's location faster than anyone had
expected and so he was able to surprise
all for one and rescue the injured all
might by literally blowing up all for
one's arms he then grabbed all might and
sped away as all might's vestage inside
of one for all returned to normal
confirming that his cruel fate had been
successfully changed bakugo declared
pred time to win this and the chapter
came to an end the latest chapter begins
with all might speaking with a vision of
seridi or I guess his soul maybe and
night ey confirms that yes this was the
moment that all might was supposed to
die a gruesome death at the hands of a
villain this was the moment that night
ey foresaw with his Quirk but in the end
things did not turn out the way that
night ey predicted fate itself was
changed thanks to the wishes of everyone
who wanted all might to live and thanks
to to the brave actions of his students
then Hoshi throws in a bit of a jab at
us the readers because all might asks
night ey what about the Trope of the
mentor dying and passing on his legacy
to the Next Generation that is certainly
a common occurrence in Shonen and many
of us expected that something similar
would happen to all might before the mha
manga came to an end however night ey
pokes fun at this idea by saying save
that for the comic books toshinori yagi
which is a pretty meta statement since
mha literally is a Japanese comic book
all might believes that this vision of
night eye is just a hallucination and he
doesn't know why a hallucination that
his own mind created would be saying
something like this but night ey signs
off by saying heroes are human too you
won't die so easily then we jump back to
the battlefield and we are literally
picking up at the same exact moment that
the last chapter left off we see all the
people who are watching the battle on TV
reacting to bakugo's daring rescue of
all might even natu from fairy tale is
there and he recognizes that the person
who rescued all might is the same
student who had been taken hostage by
the league of villains leading up to the
famous battle of kamino some of the
viewers are trying to remember his name
but then we see mahoro and katsuma from
the second mha movie immediately
recognizing that it is in fact bakugo
it's interesting that hodik Koshi is
showing us characters from the second
movie Just when so many of us are
speculating that the conclusion of the
second movie might repeat itself in this
battle and thatu might end up sharing
the power of one for all with bakugo and
maybe even with other people kind of
like he did in the climax of the second
movie bakugo then places all might down
on the ground and stands over him
protectively all might asks bakugo if
he's okay but bakugo says that's my line
you decrepit old fart I guess some
things never change and bakugo's cringey
insults are not going away anytime soon
that said bakugo starts coughing up
blood and he is clearly still in bad
shape physically so even though he's
mocking all might's physical condition
all might is like bro are you okay and
then freaking edshot shows up just like
in the form of a stitch that he was
using to seal the wound in bakugo's
chest and it seems that edshot can
literally talk from inside bakugo's body
edshot says that he forced bakugo to
vomit because there was too much
internal bleeding so he needed to expel
some of that blood from his stomach I
have no idea how medicine works but okay
I guess Ed shot then leaves bakugo's
body and he looks like a little snake
thing made of like strings and stuff in
short he looks very weird let's just say
that and yet he is still able to talk
somehow edshot says that using the hakam
style secret ninja nodding technique and
his own stretchy body he was able to
repair all of bakugo's broken bones and
injured organs meaning that bakugo is
now in stable condition and his insides
won't collapse from his injuries however
bakugo will still be in incredible pain
because of all the injuries he sustained
and in fact even lifting a finger will
hurt a lot it's not an ideal solution
but it's the best that Baku can hope for
at this point in time bakugo then thanks
his Senpai edshot for saving his life
but here's an interesting twist edshot
says that bakugo is wrong to think that
he was the one who saved his life edshot
just managed to bound everything
together physically but no matter how
hard he tried to jump start bakugo's
heart and lungs he was simply unable to
wake him up edshot was at his limit
using this technique eats away at his
own life so he was quickly running out
of time and yet nothing he could do
could wake bakugo up then suddenly he
saw something coming through bakugo's
bloodstream it was one of bakugo's own
sweat spheres one of the ones he
produced just before dying so if I
understand this correctly edshot bound
bakugo's body back together but it was
actually this sweat sphere that exploded
and jump started bakugo's organs back to
life including his heart it was bakugo's
own Quirk that he worked so hard for
years to strengthen that ended up saving
his life in the end bakugo's own hard
work training and sacrifice is what
ultimately provided him with a second
chance at life and this is super
interesting it's almost like bakugo
Quirk moved on its own like it had a
consciousness of its own kind of like
one for all but more on that later Hugo
then asks who's that shiny kid that kind
of gives off all for one Vibes and all
might is like yeah that's all for one
all might then offers his Gauntlet to
bakugo as a splint for his wounded arm
and as he gives the item to his student
all might calls him by his full hero
name great explosion murder God dynamite
and honestly I've said it before and
I'll say it again I love bakugo hero
name and I think it's epic many people
say it's too edgy or too cringey but I
think it's both bad bad ass and
hilarious and I fully support bakugo's
choice in this regard yes his insults
are cringy but the hero name he picked
for himself is top tier if you agree
with me drop a like for great explosion
murder God Dynamite right now all might
apologizes because this broken Gauntlet
is all that he can give bakugo right now
and bakugo responds with like the most
genuine smile we've ever seen him give
anyone honestly this was a really
powerful moment and it got me feeling a
little bit emotional I'm not going to
lie ever since he was a child bakugo
always put up this tough front and he's
Brash and loud and rude towards everyone
and sometimes he was even an outright
bully but the truth is that bakugo was
always as much of an all might Fanboy as
deu and we know that back when all might
had to retire after the battle in kamino
bakugo blamed himself because he allowed
himself to be kidnapped by the villains
which led to the battle in the first
place so seeing bakugo now SM smiling so
genuinely as he knows that he was the
one who saved all might's life is pretty
incredible as Baku and all might are
having their moment young all for one is
finally starting to panic he realizes
that he is running out of time and that
he needs to reach shigaraki and force
the copy of all for one that he
possesses into shigaraki's body he
reminds us that having two copies of the
All For One Quirk inside of shigaraki's
body is the only thing that can overcome
shigaraki's strong will and ensure that
all for once's personality will take
over the body and yet even as he knows
what his priorities should be and that
he is running out of time all for one is
consumed with rage because everything
seems to be going wrong his master plan
which he spent so long preparing and
putting into motion is failing because
in so many instances the heroes have
defied expectations they fought harder
than expected they sacrificed more than
expected and they even changed fate
itself because they refused to give up
before all for one can get it together
bakugo lunges at him grabs his face and
proclaims I'm your final boss all for
one upon seeing bakugo up close over for
one thinks of the second one for all
user and in the very next moment a
massive explosion seems to destroy the
villain's body uninjured but smiling
bakugo exclaims that he is the guy who
steps in when that nerd deu can't handle
things on his own and that is how this
absolutely epic chapter ends wow bakugo
definitely came back with a bang and I
absolutely loved his moment with all
might probably the most interesting
thing about the whole chapter was the
fact that even after bakugo died his
Quirk seemed to move on its own and the
sweat sphere that he left behind was
able to jump start his heart and other
organs after edshot managed to repair
them now we already know that one for
all can act on its own thanks to the
vestages and sometimes they can even
helpu when he is in trouble like during
his battle against against shinso so did
bakugo squirk gain that same ability
because he briefly inherited the ability
to use one for all during the second
movie and then maybe some part of one
for all mixed with bakugo's own Quirk at
that time or is bakugo quirk evolving in
some other way and it is gaining a form
of sentience as it awakens into a
completely different overpowered Quirk
let me know what you guys think did
bakugo's Quirk just evolve and become
sentient did did somehow Fus with one
for all during the events of the second
movie but the side effects of that
Fusion are only being revealed now our
deu and bakugo about to initiate another
epic Quirk Fusion technique oh and what
will happen to our boy edshot is he
going to recover or is he going to
remain that creepy string snake thing
forever don't forget to leave your
thoughts down in the comments below if
you're looking for more epic mha videos
to watch right now check out my full mha
playlist link on screen and in the
description if you enjoyed this video
and you want to see more in the future
leave a quick like right now and if you
want to help this channel awaken the
true power of its Quirk by hitting 2
million subscribers do me a huge favor
and subscribe right now we are so close